[Music]
happy holidays cheers the holidays are
here and prince harry and meghan markle
are ringing things in with a low-key
california christmas
and the launch of their podcast welcome
to archwell audio
no he has a podcast voice a source tells
et the couple are planning to keep it
chill for their first christmas in the
u.s
spending the holiday with their
one-year-old son archie and
meg's mama doria pretty special
quote megan who is an accomplished cook
will be preparing some of their favorite
dishes with harry and doria pitching in
i never thought my life would be that
awesome our source adds that they
initially had plans to return to the uk
in january for megan's case against
associated newspapers and the mail on
sunday
but since the case was postponed until
next fall the source says there's no
imminent plans to go
overseas especially given the travel
restrictions related to the pandemic
oh and the lovebirds they'll be busy
stateside with a new project
should we should we start no ladies
first
no say it because i think it sounds
really nice with your accent well i'll
talk audio
yeah archweal audio i mean really
shall we yeah let's do it on tuesday
spotify announced that they struck a
partnership with the duke and duchess of
sussex's newly formed audio production
company
archwell audio we are so fortunate harry
and megan's company will produce
programming aimed at
uplifting and entertaining audiences
around the world
and will include original podcasts
produced and hosted by the couple
hi guys i'm harry and i'm megan
one of the things my husband and i have
always talked about is our passion for
meeting people and hearing their stories
and no matter what the story they
usually offer you an understanding of
where someone else is coming from
and at the same time remind you in some
way of a story about yourself
spotify released a teaser for the
project on tuesday
and it sounds like everything we need in
2020.
that's what this project is all about to
bring
forward different perspectives and
voices
that perhaps you haven't heard before
and find our common ground
because when that happens change really
is possible and you know this is also a
moment to celebrate
kindness and compassion something we saw
in so many places this year
and which will underlie everything you
hear from archwell audio
while the couple's first complete series
won't debut until 2021
a holiday special is set to premiere
later this month
we're talking to some amazing people
they're going to share their memories
that have really helped shape
this past year which has been as we know
a difficult one for everyone
so many people have been through so much
pain this year
experiencing loss a huge amount of
uncertainty
but it feels worth acknowledging that
2020 has connected us in ways
we should have never imagined through
endless acts of compassion and kindness
and what really matters is clear now
more than ever